[Music]
so it is very cold wet and rainy here in
Jacksonville so what better way to spend
a day creating than to make a very moody
song that reflects the weather right now
I've had this poured progression in my
head for quite some time now definitely
again focusing on the rubber Bridge
sound which is kind of like the overall
theme to my album which if you don't
know this current video series I'm
working on my album called good things
take time but the Riff that I've had in
my head for quite some time now is sort
of like a folky Americana so let's pull
up logic and see what we come up with so
this riff idea came to me when I was on
a walk the other day but my guitar is
tuned down a whole step so you get this
really really gnarly sound out of it but
the Riff is
and I thought as well like in the
choruses that F
shape to
C something like that so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to run through
the entire song uh I'm just going to hum
like a melody over it and I'm going to
use this as my scratch track and then
I'll just base the rest of the song off
of the scratch
[Music]
track so yeah I want to keep the melody
just very simple uh I'm kind of going
for like bony ve Gigi Perez just like
the guitars are going to be purposely
kind of messy and the song is going to
feel just like a bunch of people with
guitars sitting around a campfire just
uh enjoying it I guess so now I'm going
to double track the rubber Bridge
guitars left and right and I think it's
just going to be a really cool sound uh
just being Indie just being weird with
it
[Music]
so I live across the street from
railroad tracks and I'm pretty sure that
you could hear the train in the last
little bit I'm going to leave it in I
think it's okay so I think I'm going to
add just where it sort of starts to pick
up add some kind of doubles but are
somewhere else on the
[Music]
neck oh that would be interesting to do
I think I'm going to add these to the
other chorus as well but just very
[Music]
light yeah kind of like
that that's that's pretty cool right so
now I'm going to switch out this guitar
with probably one of my Martin all right
and the purpose of this as well uh my
mic position is just randomly back I'm
not trying to get like a really clear
guitar sound here I'm purposely pushing
the microphone back where it just sounds
like this guitar is in the room so it
may not end up sounding good it could
sound good I guess we'll find out
[Music]
yeah that sounds pretty cool I think I'm
going to add another kind of that plugy
guitar but with this now just to layer
it a little bit and for this I think I
am going to get the microphone a little
closer just to get more detail
[Music]
all right so I think now just to add a
little bit of a sense of Rhythm I'm
going to add like a kick in a tambourine
I don't want to fall victim to sounding
like every folk song from like the
mid-2010s there definitely won't be any
in this song so I have to be very
selective about the sounds that I pick I
want this song to be able to hold up in
really any context and any time so I'm
going to use something from the indie
folk expansion pack from Easy
Drummer I don't know if I'm really
falling in love with this kick drum
sound but let's just try it I don't
think I want drums until the second
verse as well so that's where I'm going
to pick it up from
[Music]
I was just messing around in between
takes and just opened up the default of
the custom shop expansion pack I think
that's actually what I'm to end up going
with it's just so much more natural
sounding so let's just see how that
[Music]
is oh no so I didn't realize how out of
time my playing was there's probably
some of you watching this who are like
yeah we noticed it the whole time but I
genuinely did not notice so what I'm
going to end up doing is record the
drums as much as I can while keeping
time on the drums and then I'm going to
have to go back and re-record all of the
guitars which normally I think is a
pretty frustrating thing but I'm a firm
believer as well is if you have to redo
something there's probably a better
reason for you probably can do it better
the next time so I'm not going to stress
about it uh I am going to finish
recording the drums I probably won't re
record the guitars today I'll save that
for tomorrow uh so I'll finish up today
with just doing the
drums so right now we are putting
together a really fun challenge for our
students in our Academy which if you
don't know what I do outside of these
production videos I help run an academy
that teaches musicians a new way of
making a living with their music and
that is for making custom bespoke music
for big brain campaigns this isn't
anything like snc licensing which you
might be familiar with no shade to sync
at all there's a lot of musicians who do
make a really good living out of that
but it is kind of like playing the
lottery meaning that you're just
creating a handful of tracks and you're
hoping for something to be picked
whereas with my world it's about making
a connection with the music production
company and then working with a producer
on composing a track from scratch for a
brand campaign right now we are working
on a scoring challenge for our students
to where over 3 days they'll have three
different briefs and it'll be like a
high-intensity workshop kind of
simulating what our industry is like so
we are very excited about that if you
want to learn more about our world go to
makingmusic forrs
docomo training where we pretty much go
over everything in the industry so I'm
going to get back to work put on some
lowii music enjoy the rain and I'll see
you guys when I see you
[Music]
so it is the next day I went ahead and
re-recorded all of the guitars in my
opinion they are much better I was much
more thoughtful as well about the
positioning of the microphone because a
main principle that I believe with when
making music especially as a producer is
to think create and record as if mixing
was not a thing meaning that when you
set up your microphone to record an
acoustic guitar be very purpose
purposeful about where you're putting
that microphone and not just sticking it
in front of your guitar because I think
that the sound that because I think that
the sound that I re-recorded is much
better than it was yesterday like I'm
listening to it and I'm like I don't
really think that there's that many
plugins that I need to put on it so I'm
much more happy with how the production
came out in today's session I want to
capture the base and maybe some Ambiance
there's not a lot of production that I
really want in this song in general I
really think that this is going to be a
less is more approach so I'm just going
to start with layering a base oh and
real quick as well something that really
helps me throughout the process uh I
went ahead and laid drums out through
the entire song just to better keep my
time I may end up taking them out I kind
of like them being left throughout the
song so I'm not too sure yet I'm just
going to leave them from now so for the
bass since there's not really a lot
going on like I don't want any crazy
bass runs like the focus should be on
the guitar s so I'm just going to use
this VST which is the Vintage Soul
preset in logic and I think it sounds
pretty good so I'm not going to make any
adjustments right now
[Music]
yeah that sounds pretty good all right
so I want to add some I guess cinematic
textures and for that I'm going to be
using Labs by Spitfire audio and I pay
for labs plus which you get like a ton
more sounds in it there's a free version
of labs as well but I do recommend
upgrading all right so let's see what we
got in here
hey hey no no no no no no the mailman
he's barking at the mailman yeah go get
the mail make yourself
useful this might be kind of a cool
little texture to layer in the
background but I can easily seeing it be
too much so let's just see what we can
do with it
[Music]
that was kind of cool so now I just got
to figure out what to do in all these
other parts
[Music]
essentially my dog just farted and it
distracted me so much that I forgot what
notes I'm playing I'm not even joking
with you right now dude look at
him he's a monster I'm telling you I
kind of just want to just see what other
elements are popping out I don't really
have an agenda with what I want things
to sound
[Music]
like maybe we could just do that I'm
trying to remember what the original
Melody that I sang
[Music]
is that's it let's see what we could do
with that little high Melody
[Music]
there so now I should find
something else to match that
[Music]
Melody and I'm just going to look for
one more element I again I don't really
know what maybe just some kind of like
overall
pad that would be really cool if it
sounds right leading in to when
everything picks up
so right
[Music]
here that's so cool
oh that was that was exactly what I was
hoping it would do okay so I have a
couple more things to work on before my
day is over again I'll come back to this
project tomorrow and that'll probably be
the last step to be honest cuz I think
what I want to add are just some
background electric guitars and then I
have to write the song and record the
vocals and then I feel like it's pretty
much done
my wife and I just came back from
getting some coffee this morning she's
out at a hair appointment so you know
what that means wife gone time to make
some music I think a couple days ago I
mentioned there's not really much left
to do on this project other than some
additional layers and then of course
doing vocals and actually writing the
song I don't feel like I can necessarily
just jump in with vocals and writing so
I'm going to start with my layers just
to kind of get re familiar because it
has been a couple days since I've opened
this project so I think the first thing
that I'm going to change is this drum
sound and pattern it is very organic but
I kind of want it to feel more uh
electronic I don't know if this is going
to be the right
move I guess not electronic it's more so
I want elements that aren't obviously a
pick and a high hat I want elements that
give off that sense of Rhythm I'm going
to open up the opw from Spitfire audio
there's a really cool percussive hits
but it's got all these sounds in it I
know there's there's kicks somewhere in
here there they are I'm going to use
this sound as my kick drum and then I'll
find something else to layer over top of
[Music]
it all right so now I want to find some
kind of copper element so I'm looking
for something to replace that high hat
[Music]
sound I think it can sound cooler I'm
going to turn up the Reverb and then
just focus on the mid
[Music]
presence that's really cool I like that
a lot
[Music]
so I just went absolutely Zero Dark 30
and just focused on this other kick
sound I was hearing cuz I'm like I
turned off the acoustic
kick and
[Music]
yet I'm hearing this like this acoustic
kick and I can't figure out where it's
coming from uh turns out it's this piano
right
[Music]
here it's the sound of the Hammers so I
got to turn that down but yeah I was
like going crazy I'm like where's this
other Kick Drum and I think I'm also
going to add just some more percussive
layers holy crap that sounds so
[Music]
cool that just brought the song into to
a completely different direction I'm
going to see if I could find like just a
really deep subbase that we can throw
some Distortion and probably some chorus
on let's just see how it sounds it might
be a little too intense but let's just
try
[Music]
I want to like it cuz it is really cool
and it stands out I think it's a little
too heavy for the vibe that we're going
for so let's go ahead and look for
another
one perfect that is exactly what I
needed
[Music]
maybe with some more
Distortion oh
[Music]
yeah you know if you put some Reverb on
this and tune it up really high do you
guys remember Congratulations by post
Malone
[Music]
[Applause]
that's such a cool sound I got to
remember this patch this is a really
cool one all right I think I need to add
just a couple of electric guitars to
fill the space a little more than what's
there already I'll probably use this
epone dot here fun fact did you guys
know that it's supposed to snow here
next week I'm in Northeast Florida that
is crazy
[Music]
okay I think that's pretty good all
right so I've written A Chorus and I
feel like once I get over this chorus
the rest of the lyrics will come more
naturally and let's just see how it
[Music]
goes where is the world that I used to
see
full of color shape and
sound never was lost
but okay I think I got the words so I'm
going to do some vocal production see
how the rest of the song is and I think
we're pretty close to being
[Music]
done and I'm questioning my life cuz
there's I got to pay and I'm
wondering living the same just ding it's
the only
one so you're D for just not
trying all right so I think I am done
with the song I'm going to do a rough
mix and master of this if you want to
see a full detailed production breakdown
of pretty much everything I'm about to
do this song with mixing I do encourage
you to sign up for my Creator kitchen it
is my monthly YouTube membership where
with every production video there will
be a detailed mix breakdown that talks
about every single plug-in every single
choice that was made in the song so I do
hope that you consider becoming a member
so like I said I'm going to mix this and
then we're going to listen to the final
result all right so let's go ahead and
take a lesson of a rough mix to the song
[Music]
this world has taking a toll on
me where is the world that I used to
[Music]
see full of color shape and
sound never was lost but I never felt
found and lose a track of time was a kid
just
yesterday and I'm questioning my life
cuz there's bills I got to pay and I'm
wondering if living is the same as just
dying when it's the only one GI so you
damn for just not trying
[Music]
this world is full of give and
take it's just not our choice to
make they always say good things take
time just if if you're willing to wait
in
F but I'm losing track of time was a kid
just
yesterday and I'm questioning my life
cuz there's bills I got to pay and I'm
wondering if living is the same it's
just not dying when it's the only one
we're giv so you damnn for just not
trying
[Music]
am going to lose a check at time
was a kid just
yesterday and I'm questioning my life
cuz there's bills I got
to in
wondering living is the same just not D
but it's the only
one so you D for just trying
[Music]
so a couple of things just listening
back to that one I am insanely proud of
this song um it definitely sounds like a
negative Doom and Gloom song but I feel
like it's more just about acknowledging
the truths in life I guess so I I don't
know I feel very proud of this I feel
like I'm starting to get back into the
rhythm of songwriting and the actual art
of songwriting now from a production
standpoint I think there are a couple
things I want to change like I think
there needs to be a much better
transition from that second chorus into
the big part whether it's like a symbol
swell or just some kind of effect that
gets us from point A to point B and then
then at the very end when it's just the
quiet guitars uh I think I should add
some kind of vocal there and just leave
like a line on a quiet note so I'll
probably end up going back and adding
that at some later point but I do want
to get this video wrapped up because the
song is at a point where I'm proud of it
I think it's a really good polish demo
that I could just expand on a little bit
oh and one more thing before we go it'll
most likely be out next week but I ended
up putting a full midi drum workshop
together I originally intended just to
put a like 2hour video together but
ended up being like a full-blown course
and I am super proud of it as far as
like the production quality and I feel
like there's a lot of value to it as
well it's probably the number one thing
that I get asked about as well so I'm
really trying to teach everything that I
know so for the first week and for the
first week only I'm going to be selling
it at 50% off and then after that it's
going to go to full price so if you want
to be on the waiting list for the midi
Drum Shop so you can be the first to
take advantage of the $50 per sign off
there will be a link in the description
for a page that you can sign up and then
as soon as it is released you'll be the
first to know so thank you guys so much
again for watching this video and I will
see you in the next one peace